I want to start by thanking Shafie for
that very generous introduction and for
inviting me here today to speak to all
of you it's a real pleasure and an honor
for particularly for an economist to be
speaking at the the Symons Institute and
particularly about computing especially
to be talking about computing in front
of a Turing Award winner it's actually
quite intimidating so I'm gonna try to
keep my comments relatively low level
and broad rather than to focus on any
kind of detailed mathematical
derivations I know that being from MIT
we have a rule that says every
PowerPoint deck has to have at least one
equation I'm gonna break that rule today
there we know equations but this is a
public lecture after all so I'm assuming
that not everybody here is well-versed
in the theory of computing what I'm
going to talk about instead is how
artificial intelligence has really
changed the way we think about financial
technology and what that implies for the
future of the field there's some really
interesting implications some troubling
concerns that I want to bring to your
attention and hopefully a way out that
I'm I'm betting that people in this
audience will be able to implement over
the course of the next few years so
that's a quick outline of what I'm gonna
try to touch on and but feel free to
interrupt with questions or comments I
know there's a Q&A period at the end but
happy to take questions earlier if you
like generally people are a little too
polite to do that but I would encourage
you nonetheless I want to start with so
I'm actually using the lapel mic as
opposed to this one so I'm hoping that
it is this is this better okay sorry
about that
yeah I'm should I hope I don't have to
repeat what I just said no okay all
right well so I want to start with a
little bit of motivation and the
motivation is this graph and the graph
looks like this anybody tell me what
this graph is
climate change that hopefully not but I
understand where you're coming from
exactly this hockey stick is world
population from 10,000 BC to the present
and it is the prototypical hockey stick
because population growth happens to be
exponential but there are very few
species on this planet that actually
have a growth curve that looks like this
you know I grew up in New York City and
during long hot summers occasionally the
population of cockroaches in New York
look like this and then you call the
exterminator and boom it comes back down
Homo sapiens have been reproducing
virtually unchecked for eons how how do
we do this and the answer of course
happens to be technology technology is
what enables us to really dominate
virtually every ecosystem on this planet
agricultural technology medical
technology manufacturing technology and
so on and it's actually easy to see this
if you look at it on a logarithmic scale
because on a log scale the slopes can
tell you the rate of growth and from
this log scale depiction you can tell
that there are maybe four or five
different unique periods in human
evolution the flat part of the curve to
the left is the Stone Age and then the
slight would upward curving part that's
the Bronze Age and then after that the
Iron Age and then the Industrial Age and
over the course of the last hundred
years we are in what I think of as the
digital age between 1900 and 2019 we
have nearly quintupled the number of
people walking this planet that is an
extraordinary amount of growth in from
an evolutionary time scale in a blink of
an eye and it is because of all these
different technologies most important of
all for the current discussion
is digital technology and so you all
know by now Moore's law better than I do
the fact that we are doubling the
capacity of chips every three to five
years my colleagues in the physics and
engineering departments at MIT tell me
that we're actually running up on a
limit to Moore's law and that may be the
case but then there's quantum computing
and who knows what that will do in terms
of being able to keep this pushing
forward and you might think that because
of progress on the tech side there has
to be an implication in financial
services and the answer is there is
there is a financial Moore's law and if
we take a look at what that looks like
let's take I don't know trading volume
as a case in point the red line here is
the amount of trading for options and
futures on various different exchanges
and what you can see is that if you do a
log scale which is the blue line and the
Green Line is the linear curve that you
fit we're doubling average daily trading
volume of financial securities about
once every seven or eight years it's not
quite the same as Moore's Law but it is
just as impressive and so it's pretty
clear that financial technology is going
through an incredible growth spurt and
many of you I suspect know this
firsthand because you're probably in the
FinTech space how many people here are
actually working on FinTech startups or
have an idea to do something along those
lines show of hands alright fair number
how many of you here are actually very
concerned about FinTech and what it
might do to society yeah good so you're
at the right place we're gonna talk
about both the positives and the
potential negatives of this set of
amazing innovations but I want to give
you one example of what an innovation in
financial technology might mean for each
one of you in the audience here and that
technology is what I'm going to call
precision indexes now you've all heard
about precision medicine coops you've
all heard about precision medicine the
idea that
can actually target therapies specific
to your particular genetic makeup in
cancer it is absolutely critical to get
your DNA sequence before a doctor will
even talk with you about treatment
options because it has become so
oriented towards customizing it for
particular individuals what about if we
did that for financial products and
services so you know instead of the Dow
Jones 30 the footsie 100 or the S&P 500
imagine being able to have the Shafi
Goldwasser 30 or the Peter Bartlett 100
of the Jim Simon's 500 an index
specifically for you that's focused on
your income expenses age health taxes
behavior like goals constraints
everything about you so that we can
design exactly the right portfolio for
you every day and imagine that this is
really smart beta in that it is totally
automated now it turns out that we now
have the means to do this we've got the
hardware we've got the software we've
got the telecommunications platforms and
this is within our grasp
now this is not a new idea by any means
a number of years ago there was a paper
published titled personal indexes and
the the concluding paragraph had this to
say about technology artificial
intelligence and active management are
not at odds with indexation but instead
imply a more sophisticated set of
indexes in portfolio management policies
for the typical investor something each
of us can look forward to perhaps within
the next decade who was this incredibly
prescient insightful sage that wrote
these words well it was written by yours
truly
but I wrote this in 2001 and so one
could argue that given that we don't
have precision indexes yet that I was
off because it's been a lot more than a
decade now I wasn't totally wrong in the
sense that we do have Robo advisors and
ETFs and mutual funds that have all
sorts of automated algorithms that
provide investors exposure to different
kinds of styles of investing but we're
not there yet and the question I want to
take up today is why not what's missing
and it turns out that it is not
artificial intelligence that's missing
what we don't have is what one of my
graduate students called artificial
stupidity
we don't have an algorithmic
understanding of how people actually
behave we have all sorts of rules and
URIs --tx about how people should behave
but we don't actually know
algorithmically how people do behave and
that's what we need before we can
actually design truly useful highly
customized precision indexes now I think
artificial stupidity is a bit strong and
obnoxious so I would change it to
artificial humanity because all of us we
make mistakes and it's not necessarily
even a bad thing because some of those
mistakes can actually save us in other
contexts so what we need are algorithms
that actually describe human behavior so
we can counterbalance the least
productive actions with various
different kinds of remedies and that's
the missing link human behavior not
understanding that human behavior can
overwhelm all of the most sophisticated
technological advances to cite that
other famous philosopher and great
humanitarian Darth Vader when sorry for
that I teach MBA students so I have to
incorporate sound effects
what when you when you are looking at
all of these sophisticated technologies
it turns out that they don't they don't
have any ability to deal with
overwhelming human behavior particularly
during crises so what I want to do now
is to talk about how do we model human
behavior because it turns out that the
way we model it is going to give us some
insight into the kind of AI the new AI
that's going to be necessary to deal
with these opportunities and challenges
so I want to begin with my own field of
economics and talk about the theory of
economic behavior how do I con amidst
s-- think about the way people
particularly investors behave and in
order to do that I'm going to take you
back to 1947 which is the year that Paul
Samuelson published his PhD thesis
titled very modestly foundations of
economic analysis remember he was a PhD
student it turned out it was modest
because his PhD thesis actually became
the foundations of modern economic
analysis at the same time von Neumann
and Morgenstern at the Institute for
Advanced Study Princeton published a
book on the theory of games and economic
behavior and these two works described a
particular paradigm known as expected
utility theory on the idea that each of
us we have these utility functions a
measure of our happiness and the way
that we can predict how humans behave is
to maximize the expected utility subject
to budget constraints and other
practical production and consumption
constraints and that will predict how it
is that people behave this theory became
so successful in academic economics that
economists emboldened by the beauty of
the mathematical precision with which
you can calculate these kinds of
solutions they started applying it to
all sorts of other domains that had
nothing to do with economics things like
a theory of divorce of suicide of
extramarital affairs and so it got to
the point where the theory of economic
behavior started becoming the economic
theory of all behavior
and the term Homo economicus arose this
idea of economic humans that people
actually behave in ways that are much
more akin to what economists think than
other disciplines so you might not be
surprised to learn that after these
theories were espoused people tested
them and the tests had mixed results
initially it looked like it worked
pretty well it certainly can predict
certain kinds of behavior but the more
you applied these tests to various
different domains that more became clear
that actually they don't fit the data
very well when I was a grad student and
an assistant professor I worked with a
colleague Craig McKinley to test the
random walk hypothesis which is one
aspect of of this theory of expected
utility maximization and what we found
was that in the data the random walk
does not hold for stock prices you could
actually predict stock prices to some
degree little did we know that at the
time we were writing this paper a
certain mathematician was applying these
ideas in trying to predict the stock
market that mathematician is now a multi
billionaire and he happens to be the
founder of the Simons Institute for the
theory of computing so we know we know
from Jim Simon's work that actually the
random walk doesn't hold but a number of
economists and psychologists came up
with all sorts of other behavioral
biases that humans seem to suffer from
and I won't take you through all of them
but I'll give you a very simple example
that I think we all face every day in
terms of how we decide on investing my
first year MBA students are confronted
with this problem in the class that I
teach and try to motivate how to think
about investing I show them the returns
of four different financial assets I
don't tell them what it is or even over
what time period they span I simply show
them what the rates of return are for $1
invested in these four assets over an
unspecified multi-year horizon and this
is what it looks like
the green line turns $1 into $2 over
this multi-year investment period not
very rewarding but not particularly
risky it's got a pretty smooth upward
slope red line turns a dollar into about
five dollars way more rewarding but way
more volatile lots more risk the blue
line turns a dollar into eight dollars
even more rewarding but way more
volatile and the black line somewhere in
between and the question that I asked
them is if you could only pick one of
these four assets you can't mix and
match them you can only pick one to put
your entire entire retirement wealth or
your children's college fund or your
your parents or grandparents life
savings if you could only choose one of
these which would you pick it's a matter
of risk versus reward right so how many
of you here would pick the Green Line
show hands anybody Wow nobody maybe one
person but okay how about the red line
anybody any takers for the red line
really only one person I want you to
remember this moment because when I tell
you what the red line is some of you are
gonna need to call your brokers the the
blue line and he take us to the blue
line okay so these are the entrepreneurs
and hedge fund managers yeah what's that
you see the graph yeah
absolutely absolutely you see this whole
thing right now and I'm asking you right
now yeah you see the graph do you like
that okay black line how many people
want black yeah virtually all the
audience's that I've talked to may
prefer the black line why because it's
got the best trade-off between risk and
reward it's not the most rewarding but
it seems to have pretty low risk well
let me tell you what you all picked
first of all the time period goes from
1990 to 2008 okay
the Green Line is US Treasury bills the
safest asset in the world at least for
the first next few weeks we'll see what
happens with the budget discussions but
not very rewarding so if you put your
money in T bills you would have earned
pretty much next to nothing over the
course of the last decade the red line
which only one of you picked that's the
S&P 500 the US stock market most of you
already have that in your 401k so if you
didn't pick it you need some rebalancing
to do but if you did pick it in 2008
congratulations you did just fine you
did quite well the blue line is a single
company Pfizer pharmaceutical company
way way way more risky not for everybody
but for the few entrepreneurs and hedge
fund protegees makes sense and if you
put your money in Pfizer well
congratulations you did even better
exactly phenomenal now what about for
the most of you who picked the black
line the black line is the return to a
private fund known as the Fairfield
century fund this was the feeder fund
for the Bernie Madoff Ponzi scheme
which is why I had to stop it in 2008
that's when the Ponzi scheme blew up now
you know how the Ponzi scheme got as big
as it did look at the number of hands
that went up it is human nature that we
are all drawn like a moth to a flame to
high yielding low-risk assets and in
finance we have a term to capture that
phenomenon it's called the Sharpe ratio
the Sharpe ratio is defined as the
expected return above and beyond t-bills
in the numerator and risk as measured by
the volatility in the denominator so you
can think of it is the amount you're
earning per unit risk and we all want
more we want more Sharpe ratio higher
Sharpe ratios and if you look at Pfizer
and the SME 500 the Sharpe ratios are
about 1/3 compared to the Bernie Madoff
Ponzi scheme before it blew up it had a
Sharpe ratio on paper that was an order
of magnitude higher sometimes when
things are too good to be true they they
aren't true now there's nothing there's
nothing patently irrational about
seeking high Sharpe ratio assets but the
problem is that our perception of risk
is highly subjective and context
dependent and can easily be manipulated
and as a result human behavior does not
always give us the best financial
outcomes but unless we understand why we
do the things that we will later regret
we can't develop the algorithms to get
around it and to do a better job that is
after all what AI is supposed to be
about it's about doing a better job that
what we can do ourselves or to do it
faster cheaper on a more broadly
distributed scale so we want we want to
focus on that how do we do that how do
we design a theory of actual behavior as
opposed to a theory of what we think
people ought to be doing the answer
was cut what was first proposed by a
computer scientist of a sort and that
computer scientist is named Herbert
Simon now before Simon became a computer
scientist and I'm not really sure that
computer scientists really feel that
he's a computer scientist before that he
was an economist and he came up with a
theory of behavior that he called
bounded rationality in 1956 Simon's
proposed something that he called
satisficing behavior that word
satisficing doesn't exist in the English
language he made it up as a combination
of satisfactory and optimizing behavior
it was a compromise and his notion was
that humans we don't optimize we don't
have a utility function that we're
trying to use the calculus of variations
to compute optimal investment
trajectories we come up with rules of
thumb heuristics we have a mental model
the mental model has a particular
prediction and we follow that prediction
and what we're wrong well so be it and
so Simon's proposed satisficing as an
alternative to expect the utility
maximization and as a result he became
totally alienated from the economics
profession now let me explain to you why
that is to do that I have to sort of
explain what the theory of satisficing
is I'm gonna give you an example of
coming up with a heuristic the example
has to do with a particular problem that
all of us face every day and that is
getting dressed in the morning what
should you wear so I'm gonna tell you
how I work with my particular challenge
by telling you first what my wardrobe
looks like so here's my wardrobe I've
got five jackets ten pairs of pants 20
ties 10 shirts 10 pairs of socks four
pairs of shoes and five belts that's my
entire wardrobe now you might think
that's a rather limited collection of
clothing but I'll have you know that if
you calculate the combinatoric s' you'll
see that I have two million unique
outfits in my closet two million unique
outfits now it's true not all of them
are equally compelling from a
fashion perspective so I have a problem
I have to choose the best outfit how do
I do that
well suppose that I optimized I trying
to calculate the expected utility across
all of these different outfits and let's
assume that it takes me one second to
evaluate the fashion content of an
outfit how long would it take me to go
through all possible outfits to see
whether I've got just the right one
turns out it'll take 23.1 days now you
could say well why me you'll do it once
and then you're done and you don't do
what ever again I promise you I have
never spent 23.1 days ever thinking
about what to wear in the morning how do
we do that yeah thank you busted that
tells me more about you than it does
about the problem
that you are a very creative individual
that does not care about socks matching
yeah thank you
very good so it turns out that in fact
we don't optimize according to Simon's
we come up with rules of thumb that are
good enough and by the way you know sort
of what these rules of thumb are right
like you're not supposed to wear white
slacks after September who said that
well my wife told me that that's a rule
or you know you shouldn't wear shorts to
a a wedding we sort of know that we come
up with different rules of thumb and
that's how we get by Simons proposed
this and he was roundly criticized by
his economic colleagues in the following
way so the idea behind satisficing is
you come up with an algorithm it's good
enough it's satisfactory it's not
perfect it's good enough well what does
that mean well presumably it means that
the cost of optimizing is going to be
balanced against the benefit of finding
a better solution right but let's think
about that for a minute
good enough means close enough to
optimal which means that the cost of
doing another optimization is not really
commensurate with the reward but how do
you know that unless you know what the
optimum is when I got dressed this
morning for this event today I didn't
spend a 23-point one day's so you know I
might have been able to come up with
just the right outfit that would make my
all of my remarks so much more
compelling that you would go off and be
totally convinced that what I was saying
was the God's truth how do I know that
if I didn't spend the time doing it that
the solution that I did come up with was
good enough and if you do know what the
optimal solution is then you don't need
to satisfice just do the optimal thing
right so so satisficing was dismissed
and actually eventually Simon who is at
Carnegie
at the time left the Economics
Department and moved over into
psychology and computer science and by
the way his work in computer science was
absolutely revolutionary for computer
science he was the first to study
algorithmic methods for playing chess
and he and Alan Newell developed some
really advanced ideas about how to come
up with a chess playing program wasn't
as good as the programs we have today
but based upon what they were working
with was really path-breaking and in
recognition of his work in AI he was
awarded the touring medal the highest
honor in computer science and Simon also
won the Nobel Prize in Economics he's
the only person to have won both of
those awards and it's astonishing that
his work has not had much impact in
economics given how important I think it
is and many others now that recognise
what he's done it wasn't until I started
thinking about it from an evolutionary
perspective that I finally came up with
a response to Simon's critics and the
response that I've come up with and
written about is this who we don't know
whether something is good enough what we
do is to do what we can right now and we
use that heuristic until and unless we
have another reason to come up with a
better one so a quick example when I was
a five-year-old growing up in New York
some marketing genius figured out that
Superman was the hero of the day so you
could sell a lot of Superman jackets to
five-year-olds if you put them emblems
on the jeans jackets and so they offered
that I saw it on TV I told my mom I
wanted this could I have a Superman
jacket and she said nope you know we
were a single-parent household we
couldn't afford it it was a luxury and
so that was it I asked her the next day
and the next day and the next day and
for about two months I asked her
everyday can I have it now how about now
can I combine it with my birthday and
Christmas present I nagged her endlessly
as most five-year-olds will do until
finally she relented and I remember the
day that she agreed to buy it was a
Friday after work we went to Alexander's
on Queens Boulevard in in Queens New
York got the jacket put it on wore it
slept in it did not take it off for the
entire weekend except when I had to take
a bath and she forced me she would not
let me wear it in the bathtub and come
Monday morning I was so excited to get
the jacket on and wear it for school I
posed in front of the mirror got up
early and looked at myself and I spent
so much time in the mirror I was late
for school and that was the first time
as a first grader I was late for school
and it was pretty traumatic because in
those days you'd go to the principal's
office and get a note from the principal
bring it back to the teacher and I
remember walking to the back of the room
where everybody was already working on
their lesson
snickering that I was late and it was so
traumatizing that over five decades
later I still remember that day as if it
were yesterday from that day forward it
did not take me any longer than three
minutes to get dressed for school and
that Urist ik the heuristic that I came
up with came about because I had a bad
experience so the negative emotional
reaction that I got forced me to come up
with a new Urist ik and the heuristic
worked quite well until I got to college
and my roommate asked me to be best man
for his wedding and at the wedding
rehearsal I showed up in shorts because
I figured it was a rehearsal not
realizing that actually you're supposed
to wear like the whole thing at the tux
and all that so heuristics are developed
in response to the environment we adapt
and so this idea of bounded rationality
requires a new theory of human behavior
Homo optim the adaptive human so this is
where I have the adaptive markets
hypothesis come to play the great
evolutionary biologist theodosius
dobzhansky said that nothing makes sense
in biology except in the light of
evolution
I would paraphrase that to say that
nothing makes sense in the financial
industry except in light of adaptive
markets
the idea being that we make mistakes but
we adapt and we change and market
dynamics are really driven by that
evolutionary process so now let me bring
this back to artificial intelligence and
contrast that with natural intelligence
in the context of adaptation and I think
you'll see where we're going with this
and what it has to do with FinTech so to
talk about the relationship between AI
and natural intelligence and bounded
rationality I want to use an example of
a piece of AI that is incredibly
effective it has to do with recommender
systems so recently I got interested in
biotech so I decided that I needed to
learn more about the industry so I I
wanted to order a book on one of the
most successful biotech companies in the
history Genentech and so I went to
Amazon like many of you would do and I
searched for genetic and I got this book
and I clicked add to my shopping basket
and as soon as I did that Amazon does
this really nasty obnoxious thing that I
just hate it showed me five other books
that other people who bought this book
also bought and sure enough I had to buy
two more really really nasty habit this
is new AI now I know that many of you
are young enough that you don't even
understand the distinction between new
AI and old AI but there was such a thing
called old AI let me tell you what that
was old AI was expert systems something
that was pioneered by actually a
Stanford faculty Edward Feigenbaum and
one of my colleagues at MIT Randy Davis
it was a system of basically rules that
were meant to capture optimal behavior
in various different scenarios so an
expert system was meant to be an
exhaustive enumeration of all possible
scenarios that you might find yourself
in and then the selection of the optimal
behavior in exactly that particular
scenario so in those days storage was
very expensive and so the programming
had to be incredibly efficient the
coding was really critical the algorithm
was incredibly sophisticated not a lot
of data not a lot of storage
possibilities
that's exactly the opposite of new AI so
it turns out that what I call new AI and
recommender systems is one example the
algorithms are actually pretty simple
what's complex is the data and it turns
out that new AI is a lot closer to
natural intelligence as far as we
understand it as far as neuro scientists
tell us that old AI old AI is actually
much closer to Homo economicus let's
figure out the optimal rules for various
different scenarios and let's do that
that's not how people behave people
behave with bounded rationality in case
you're interested a couple years ago
there was a really neat review paper
published on the Amazon recommender
system and they acknowledge that the
early version was actually pretty simple
they've gotten some more sophisticated
versions since then but the early
version that worked pretty well and
obviously made Amazon what it is today
it is remarkably effective but it really
started to work well when they got
enough data so data is key so I want to
talk a bit about that and I'm going to
talk about it in the human context I
want to talk about something that all of
us have already been adapted to doing
and that is threat identification I'm
going to show you a picture and I'm not
gonna tell you what it is but I want you
to tell me as quickly as possible just
shout it out whether or not this picture
is Friend or Foe does it represent any
kind of a threat or is it benign okay
you ready all right here we go friend or
foe
you know I'm getting both because
basically who knows what is it it's just
a bunch of random pixels he can't really
tell not enough data by the way the
correct biological answer is pho what
you don't know can kill you so from the
evolutionary perspective you should be
afraid of this but we are much more
rational today so we don't know all
right let me give you the same picture
but with a few more pixels friend or foe
well it's looking pretty threatening
right okay one more picture friend or
foe
so this is a selfie of yours truly at
the Washington DC spy museum getting
stalked by a ninja but in fact it's not
a real ninja it's pretty clear this is
obviously not threatening at all so
threat identification is something that
we can do instinctively but only if we
have enough data right data is critical
all right so let me give you a more
complex this is a very simple example
I'm gonna give me a more complex example
the next example has to do also with
friend or foe but this has to do with
something that all of us have done we've
gone to a cocktail parties where we've
met lots of different people and during
the course of the evening you'll find
out different things about different
people you run into and you may or may
not have a goal but let's suppose that
you're trying to figure out who you
might want to work with or who you might
like to be friends with so you want to
learn whether or not you're compatible
with these various different individuals
in particular you might learn over the
course of an evening conversation about
their gender sexual orientation marital
status race ethnicity age group so on
and so forth okay so I'm gonna tell you
about two particular individuals that
you will run into in this course of a
hypothetical evening and I'm going to
ask you to make three decisions about
these two individuals so the two
individuals are Jose and Susan and let
me first tell you about Jose Jose is a
gay Latino male single young
professional from California was a no
religious affiliation Adam
Kratts middle-class with an MBA now let
me tell you about Susan Susan is a
heterosexual married female white
middle-aged from Texas Christian
Republican affluent with a bachelor's
degree okay so now I'm going to ask you
to make three decisions about Jose and
Susan decision number one you're about
to launch a tech startup and you need to
hire somebody to help you with the
business you need a partner for that
startup who would you rather hire Jose
or Susan how many people would hire Jose
for the startup okay how many people
hire Susan alright most of you would
hire Jose okay
okay second second you are in the
process of organizing a fundraiser to
raise money to help breast cancer
patients and so you need to get somebody
to help you organize that fundraiser you
know make phone calls to plan the event
and so on who are you gonna call who are
you gonna ask to help you with that
breast cancer fundraiser Jose or Susan
how many Google ask Jose
how about Susan okay third decision
you're working at the Internal Revenue
Service as an auditor and you're looking
for tax evaders people that have
submitted faulty fraudulent tax returns
you can't audit everybody and in
particular you can only audit either
Jose or Susan for tax fraud who would
you audit how many of you would audit
Jose how many people would audit Susan
Wow that's amazing
I can't believe how judgmental you
people are you've never met these people
you're making decisions about hiring and
auditing and all these how is that
possible now it's true I asked you but
you didn't hesitate you were able to
make decisions like that
and there was consensus there was
consensus yes I know this is Berkeley
and that's why I ask these questions it
turns out that human nature and
evolution has given us cognitive
abilities to make snap judgments and
from an evolutionary perspective believe
it or not this is it a feature not a bug
but the key is do we have enough data
now now let's look at the facts here
first of all I've listed next to each of
these characteristics the number of
broad categories that you might think of
as being possible over the course of an
evening conversation into bucketing
these individuals so two major genders
two major sexual orientations so there
are four possibilities I know there are
more if you're a more complex individual
marital status you know single married
divorced race ethnicity their four major
races age group you know four major age
groups and so on if you calculate the
number of unique combinations of these
features it turns out that you've got
over a million different categories
that's more resolution than a 600 by 800
photograph but the problem is this how
many people here have met more than a
million people in their lives nobody I
actually gave a presentation to a group
of marketing people and three people
raised their hands I don't know if I
believe them so if you have not met more
than 1 million 36 thousand 800 people
that means that some of the cells are
empty in your data storage of all
peoples because the way that we make
decisions the way that you made your
snap judgments
ghost something like this of all the
people that I can think of that raised
money for breast cancer how many of them
look like Jose versus how many of them
look like Susan well I think I'm gonna
go with Susan of all of the people that
I know that have been volved in tech
startups how many of those people look
like Jose versus how many people look
like Susan I'm gonna go with Jose so we
are doing exactly what Amazon does the
problem is that our data is incredibly
sparse most of our entries are empty we
don't have a fully populated database
yeah yes I'm gonna I'm gonna get the
baseless stereotyping the reason that we
have baseless stereotyping is because it
doesn't take much when you've got no
data to flip the bit and small things
will change your impressions of entire
classes of people things actions and
various phenomenon that means that all
the various different biases that can
emerge can emerge really easily when
you've got a sparse data set and you're
allowed to manipulate bits at will this
is one of the reasons why fake news is
so dangerous it doesn't take a lot to
change the way you act based upon the
sparse data that you currently have and
people who know that they can do
enormous amounts of damage I can do that
with financial services because I know
that there are certain things that you
care about like Sharpe ratio so if I
show you a few graphs that give you the
sense that gee it's not a lot of risk
and huge upside I can manipulate your
data set to the point where you will
easily flip from no I don't want to
invest - yeah give me a hundred thousand
dollars of that security yeah
is the other government ask Oh sort of
tell this story about how we as people
make reference but the majority of
people in the room didn't raise their
hands for any of your three questions
yes the majority of us have an awareness
and that's insufficient data to make
your time
so today you're sort of telling a story
about how people act while apparently
most people in the room don't reflect
the story well so I I'm not sure I agree
with you that most people didn't raise
their hands I saw a lot of hands go up
so it was not like four or five people
raised hands so let's say maybe half the
people raised their hands okay that's
fair right yeah that's a lot of people I
mean that's enough people to carry the
vote of a particular issue well I could
argue the other point which is that
there are many people that would have
made the snap judgement but don't want
to say and are embarrassed to say but in
fact you don't have to to reveal to me
ask yourself how many times have you
made a snap judgment about somebody I
don't want to be his friend because you
know he doesn't like soccer and I love
soccer and so I don't want to be friends
with anybody doesn't like soccer what a
ridiculous thing to say the person could
be you know an enormous li beneficial
friend to you and yet they just don't
happen to like soccer because they were
hit in the head with a soccer ball when
they're in fifth grade yeah yes agree
yeah that's right that's right it's much
more complex than this of course but on
the
you cannot come up first exactly
thank you that that's the point the
point is that all of us even with the
ideal situation where none of your
issues arise I argue that you cannot
come up with good decisions all the time
but if you now add your considerations
it is far worse and to get back to the
point about bias one thing that I didn't
talk about was path dependence meaning
that the weights on these different
feature vectors are going to be
different depending on your experiences
so if you were riding on the New York
City subways and you happen to be mugged
by somebody that was wearing green face
paint from that day forward when you see
somebody with green face paint
you're gonna think twice before being in
a room with them by themselves so it is
highly path dependent TMI I don't want
to go there yeah agreed
fine the point is that in in order for
us to deal with all of the foibles of
human behavior we need to talk about
these issues we need to think about how
it is that artificial humanity can
actually be modeled so I won't talk a
bit about what the implications are for
the financial system this is an area
that I think about more often than not
but I'm gonna give you one example about
some research that I've been doing that
will give you a sense of where I think
the future of financial AI might be if
this has to do with very specific
financial behavior that I call the freak
out factor and it is nothing more
complex than when the markets go down
investors can freak out meaning gets
scared and you decide I can't take this
anymore I've lost ten percent on the
market I got to get out I want to put
everything in cash that's what I call
freaking out so oh well the interest
rates there are many reasons yeah it
could be
there are many triggers that could be
causing the freakout factor so I'm
focusing on the state of freaking out it
turns out that freaking out
hashing out your risky security to put
them into cash generally is not a good
thing and in a minute I'll tell you how
not a good thing it is so in a paper
that I just finished with some of my
students and former colleagues daniel
alkyne Kati Kaminsky quinoa and she came
Wong we asked the question can you
predict who's gonna freak out because if
you can you can then step in and
intervene with precision indices and say
no no you you're about to freak out
because we just lost 10% in the stock
market interest rates are down and
you're worried about the future so I
want to target you as being somebody
that's likely to freak out can you do
this well it turns out you have to
define what it means a freak out so let
me give you a very simple definition of
freaking out there are other definitions
you come up with but it's a simple one
imagine that you have a portfolio at a
brokerage firm and within a month your
portfolio value declines by 90 percent
now that could be for one of two reasons
either the market goes down by 90
percent or you've liquidated part of
that let's suppose that the value goes
down by 90 percent
and on top of that you sold at least 50
percent of your portfolio during the
month that's what I call freaking out do
we agree on that there are less extreme
versions of freaking out but do we agree
that if your portfolio balance goes down
by 90 percent
and somewhere during the month you
liquidated half of your risky holdings
that constitutes as freaking out okay it
turns out that we were able to get a
large brokerage firm to give us data on
their retail investors about 650
thousand individual accounts that spread
across about 300,000 households over a
13 year period from 2003 to 2015 so this
includes the financial crisis and they
gave us monthly snapshots of individual
portfolios their trading activity and
their demographics all of this anonymize
so we don't know who they are but we
have the data and the question that we
want to ask what the data is can we
predict who freaks out
now first let me show you what
freak-outs look like so this graph
represents the percentage of individual
accounts that had freaked out in that
given year so this is a year by month by
month over the course of the last 13
years and you can see that their
periodic spikes and if you overlay a
graph of financial market dislocation
you can see that those spikes occur at
the times when the financial crisis hit
Bear Sterns going under Lehman going
under and so on so clearly people
freaked out
9% of all households in our database
freaks out at least once and so the
question is does freaking out help or
does it hurt and let me show you these
are the returns of the median household
that freaked out so of that 9% of the
households you take that sample and you
look at the median and you look at their
returns one month to two months three
months ten months twelve months after
they freaked out how do they do well the
returns you can see are mostly zero
because they're out of the market so
they're not making any money and so by
and large it seems that freaking out is
actually not subtracting a lot of
returns there is one case where during
the pre-crisis period if you freak out
for more than a year that's actually not
good news you actually lose value but by
and large it doesn't seem like you're
losing anything because you're going to
cash but that's not the correct question
the correct question is what if you
didn't freak out what would you have
earned in that case and that's this
graph this graph shows you the
hypothetical portfolio at the time you
freaked out it freezes that snapshot and
it calculates what would have happened
to those securities if you had left them
alone for one month two months three
months and so on and you can see that
the Green Line which is the post-crisis
period the red line which is the
pre-crisis period
in both cases had you left the money in
and instead of pulling it out you would
have actually done better so that's what
you lost an opportunity cost but look at
this look at the blue line the blue line
is what you would have earned had you
not freaked out during the crisis and
what it shows is over an 18 to 24 month
period freaking out was actually good
for you it's actually good to freak out
when of course you've got the right
thing to freak out about under extreme
circumstances it doesn't cost you to get
out of the market but what does cost you
is waiting too long to get back in and
therein lies the challenge there's an
opportunity there to help investors
navigate around the freakout factor by
helping them to get out of the market
when it's extreme enough and getting
back in when the coast is clear so to
the answer the question can we identify
who's going to freak out because we know
it's a big issue the answer not
surprising is yes you can it's a little
bit complicated and take a look at the
paper if you're interested particularly
because as we said most people don't
freak out so you can have you have a
very good prediction by just assuming
yeah you're not going to freak out so
you've got to pick a balance data set do
the usual machine learning calculations
to try to balance it and be able to
perform the appropriate modeling but
when you do it seems like you can
actually tell who's going to freak out
so let me give you a little bit of a
quiz and show you what it is that we
found I'm gonna ask you to tell me who
is more likely to freak out all right of
these various different characteristics
investors who are between the ages of 45
to 85 do you think they're more likely
to freak out or less likely to freak out
then typical how many people think more
how about less now it seems about even
turns out more not surprisingly the
older you are the more you have to lose
the more you worried about retirement so
you tend to freak out more what about
females is there any gender difference
between males and females
how many people think females are more
likely to freak out how about less
likely to freak out you're right
less likely this is why females actually
make better portfolio managers at least
in the context of retail investments
how about married investors are married
investors likely to freak out more or
less how many people think more how many
people might think less more more once
you're married
one could argue the stakes are higher
are you thinking about a family you've
got two people that you need to think
about how about investors with
self-declared
excellent investment experience
knowledge when you sign up for a
brokerage account you have to actually
list your own investment experience so
these are people that are excellent
investors in their own eyes more more
likely to freak out less likely you're
right more likely to freak out
households with a larger number of
dependents more kids more likely to
freak out or less likely more likely
less you're right more social workers
paralegals and government related
workers more or less likely to freak out
more likely less likely yes you're right
less likely and finally self-employed
real estate moguls what do you think
more likely to freak out less likely
yeah more likely you see we're going
with this
it turns out that with enough data we
actually have a pretty good handle on
which of you is likely to overreact to
certain market moves not only can we
know who it is but we think that we can
actually predict when you're likely to
do that at what point are you likely to
freak out here's a little teaser it
turns out that people who have done more
than one trade in their account over the
last thirty days has five times more
likely to freaking out than somebody who
has not done a trade in the last 30 days
so imagine if we actually had an
algorithm and the data to predict who
and when will freak out and we can then
intervene to prevent them from doing the
thing that we know based upon historical
data is going to give them a
disadvantage in building wealth and
suppose that we allow the algorithm to
manage this process entirely and program
the algorithm with a goal to maximize
your long-term wealth talk about a truly
greedy algorithm this would be it
that's what we're looking for precision
indices right but is greed good we
stopped to ask the question should we
really be maximizing everybody's long
term wealth of course that's right right
greed is good where is it well let me
give you one perspective the point is
ladies and gentlemen that greed for lack
of a better word is good greed is right
greed works greed clarifies cuts through
and captures the evolutionary spirit
greed in all of its forms greed for life
for money love knowledge has marked the
upward surge of mankind and greed you
mark my words will save not only Teldar
paper but that other dysfunctional
corporation called the USA thank you
very much no no points that I've asked
do does anybody does anybody know where
that's from yeah
turns out that in 1987 oliver stone
released the film wall street featuring
gordon gekko the fictitious corporate
raider and interestingly enough this
character was based upon somebody a
number of people but in particular that
speech that Greta's good speech was
based upon a speech that was given right
here at Berkley a few years before by
Ivan Boesky
at the Business School Oliver Stone made
this movie to illustrate to the public
how disgusting and dangerous financial
innovation is and how this culture of
corporate greed has to be checked and so
you could imagine his consternation when
years later people would talk to him see
him in a restaurant or write him a
letter saying I want to thank you for
making the movie because I became a
stockbroker because of it I became an
investment banker because seriously this
movie did more for MBA programs and
business schools than anything else that
I could have imagined and this is the
challenge with corporate culture it's
that somehow we have lost sight of the
role that ethics plays in these contexts
now that's not completely true we
haven't totally lost sight of it because
in the financial industry we've actually
thought about this to a great extent the
role of ethics and financial
transactions has actually played a very
significant role in the regulations that
are imposed the way that we've dealt
with how we deal with all of these
various different conflicts is the
notion of fiduciary duty a fiduciary is
somebody that is required legally to put
your interests in front of their own and
so it turns out that in situations where
you're worried about conflicts you have
to ask the question is the counterparty
that you're dealing with are they a
fiduciary it turns out that many brokers
are not fiduciaries so when you buy a
stock from a broker at your favorite
brokerage firm
they are not under legal obligation to
represent your interest solely a
financial adviser on the other hand is
and they are held to a higher standard
so it turns out that in dealing with
human interactions we realize that we've
got to deal with this in a very specific
way and so we've come up with a
mechanism for doing so do we have that
mechanism for AI not yet this is part of
artificial humanity as well so it turns
out that there actually have been
discussions about this in AI a very old
one that all of you I'm sure know from
fiction and that is the Three Laws of
Robotics that Isaac Asimov proposed in
1942 for those handful of you that
aren't nerdy enough to know what they
are let me tell you the first law of a
robot that Isaac Asimov proposed in his
I Robot stories is a robot may not
injure a human being or through inaction
allow a human being come to harm number
one rule number two rule a robot must
obey the orders given it by human beings
except where such orders would conflict
with the first law and then the first
law takes precedence the third law says
a robot must protect its own existence
as long as such protection does not
conflict with the first or second laws
so like a typical computer scientist
would do they've constructed a recursive
structure beautiful theory but it wasn't
until Isaac Asimov came to the
foundation series that he developed the
zeroeth law he realized that he forgot
something and the zeroeth law does
anybody remember what that is yeah
exactly
so Ozma realized that when you start
thinking not just about individual human
interactions with robots but you're
talking about
the entire humanity you need a law to
cover that and so here's what the zeroth
law is a robot may not injure humanity
or by inaction allow humanity to come to
harm
but when he proposed the zeroeth law
he didn't describe whether or not you
should revise the first law to make that
recursive let's suppose we did that if
we made the first law recursive which
means the first law you can't injure a
human except if it conflicts with the
zeroeth law
well now that raises a really
interesting conundrum it raises a
conundrum that we have already dealt
with as humans which is does it make
sense to commit murder if in doing so
you save the lives of many and what
would happen if you had an AI that
actually had these four laws recursively
and they started working at ExxonMobil
and started thinking about what it means
for climate change what they're doing
and for Humanity that gets really
complicated now I'm not smart enough to
know how to think about that but I know
people in this room who are and so I'm
hoping that Shafi and her colleagues
take this on to think about how ethics
and culture can actually be quantified
and embodied in what I call artificial
humanity so let me wrap up by saying
that financial technology is not just
about Homo economicus that used to be
what it was about but in my view that's
not the future of FinTech artificial
humanity figuring out how people
actually make decisions and developing
the tech to prevent us from the worst of
those decisions and helping us to come
up with the best that's truly advanced
AI and you know ethics culture policy
these are things that traditionally are
not part of quantitative analysis but I
think they ought to be because these
issues are far too important to be just
the left to philosophers politicians and
lawyers that's the traditional domain of
their expertise but it doesn't mean that
we can't take these ideas and try to
start quantifying them otherwise the
lawyers will have
final say and you know I was reminded
just a few weeks ago about how worrisome
that can be when I was told the story
about a lawyer who took on a client an
elderly woman who wanted some help with
a will and the lawyer said the fee is
$100 and she said fine she paid him in
cash hundred-dollar bill and then she
got the advice that she needed and left
and after she left the lawyer looked at
the hundred dollars and realized it was
actually two hundred dollar bills that
were there hadn't been separated and so
he immediately was confronted with an
ethical dilemma should he share it with
his partners if you didn't laugh at that
joke
you need some artificial humanity thank
you yes thank you oh wait wait wait for
that microphone you mentioned that we're
using artificial intelligence or will
you we are we're trying to understand
how human behaves and use artificial
intelligence to guide us or to make the
world a better place but what if come
certain companies or maybe government's
used this and understand understood
humanity and how we behaved and used
their agendas to shape our opinions and
shape our yeah that's the right word for
it shaped our opinions so that in the
future the opinions that we think that
we're adapt adapting are not our
opinions but the opinions that are
driven by these governments or
organizations yep I think that that's a
real danger and that's one of the
reasons why in my view the technology
field
a much broader responsibility than
simply producing great products it's
because these products have system-wide
societal impact that we don't fully
understand and any technology no matter
what it is can either be used or abused
and the kind of technology that's being
developed right here in the Bay Area is
no different but the big difference is
that the the individuals in the policy
world may not have the expertise to
understand the implications of these
technologies and the people in the
technology field may not feel that they
should be involved in policy and so what
I'm suggesting is we need to have both
come together and start thinking about
these issues and it's already happening
it's happening here there a number of
lectures that I've seen online from the
Simons Institute focusing on algorithms
and the law and various kinds of
challenges that technology is posing on
how we govern but I think that we need
we need smarter people to come into the
field people in this audience need to
start taking these kinds of issues
seriously thank you yes hi now in the
financial world your system kind of
ignores the fact that all the actors are
not independent that they are integral
related yes and you know in order for
there to be winners there have to be
losers so if you've developed algorithms
that made everyone a winner then no one
would win well so let me try to
challenge that perspective in certain
contexts you're absolutely right that
it's a zero-sum game but there's
actually a pretty large part of finance
that's not a thorough sum game and let
me give you an example a very clear
example to make this explicit so when
you buy a stock and if it goes up then
you won and the person who sold it to
you he was the knucklehead that lost
right because that person didn't
participate but that's assuming that the
person was trading as opposed to trying
to get liquidity so for example the
person that sold you the stock might not
be trying to trade but trying to cash
out in order to pay
for his kids college education in which
case he does mind that he's not getting
the benefits of the growth in the
company he doesn't want to take any more
risk he wants to use the money to
transform it from financial to
educational capital and so that's an
example where typically when we think of
a zero-sum game even in the context of
stock market trading it's not always a
zero-sum game
but there are cases where it is and as
long as you know where it that it is
that's fine
two mutually consenting adults that want
to engage in a particular game of chance
where one loses and the other wins
that's fine as long as they understand
and could withstand those kinds of gains
and losses I would argue that for the
vast majority of financial transactions
they're actually not zero-sum games
there are actually very positive gains
of trade that we engage in because
contrary to popular belief much of the
transactions that go on in financial
markets is not day traders it's people
that are shifting assets from risky to
risk list or risk list to risky
looking for long term growth and that's
really how markets ultimately will
provide better value for society yes so
I'm curious I got a question about the
impact of artificial intelligence on
financial theory or in particular the
field of artificial intelligence the
subfield I'm interested in is a natural
language processing that is computers
reading textual data maybe newspapers or
other yo just not numbers like your text
data and like you know I've seen in the
new some reason you know advances and
this sort of technology so it's curious
how much of an influence currently this
sort of natural language processing is
used and you know financial theory
whether you felt like it's going to be
more involved in the near future it's
gonna be yeah yeah so that's a really
interesting point I would say that it
hasn't really been used in financial
theory but it's been used in financial
data analysis so for example some of my
colleagues and I wrote a paper on
looking at Twitter feeds and seeing
whether or not certain patterns of text
can actually lead to changes in stock
market performance or the minutes of Fed
meetings
if you read those minutes for positive
or negative commentary whether or not
that has an impact in stock market no
those kinds of methods of using natural
language processing to do financial
research is becoming more and more
commonplace but that's not really
affecting the theory of for now yeah
definitely and that's actually one of
the really interesting areas in the
financial industry where you
traditionally had fundamental analysis
that people reading research reports and
making decisions based upon textual
qualitative information then you've got
on the other hand quants that are using
all of these various analytics to make
decisions yes algorithmically those two
are actually merging thanks to natural
language processing because if you can
read it and quantify it you can actually
develop an algorithm to manage it if you
remember the name of the paper that you
mentioned it's on my website oh yeah
good co-author with Pablo azar and yeah
it's it's on I forget the exact title
something on looking at Twitter and the
wisdom of crowds yes up there so I wish
Isaac Asimov was still around I didn't
know about the zeroth law and the the
enormous conflict between the zeroth law
and the first law yes and it seems like
this is a little bit like Stalinism how
many people do you have to murder for
the sake of humanity and this is what
Stalin did yeah and so I'm kind of
interested the first three laws were
generated in 1942 at that time we were
allied with Stalin okay and so maybe
it's understandable that he had that
mindset but what what happened with that
it seems like that would be a very
controversial idea well it certainly is
a controversial idea and I obviously
I've never met dr. Asma off so I can't
speak for him but if I had to conjecture
how the zeroeth law came to be it
actually came out of one of the
foundation books that he wrote
and in the foundation which is a one of
the reasons I went into economics it's a
it's a fictional account of a
mathematician named Harry Selden who is
a psycho historian a field that he
created using mathematical methods to
predict human behavior but those
mathematical methods only would work if
the population of the planet grew to a
certain size were the law of large
numbers and the central limit theorem
would hold and so as part of what Asimov
did that story he had Selden put
together a set of plans for Humanity
that would guide it towards a very
positive trajectory but Selden also
predicted that if certain other things
occurred it could actually lead the
planet to a very bad outcome and and so
he had to keep secret all of these ideas
and also think about how to implement
them in ways that would actually allow
the higher path to be followed and my
sense is that Ozma when he was thinking
about those ideas realized that if you
want to maximize the greater good right
the greatest good for the greatest
numbers that's the typical utilitarian
philosophy that Jon Stewart mills and
other utilitarians espoused the greater
good for the greater number leads in
some cases to necessary deaths as
difficult as it is for us to acknowledge
the classic example is the trolley
problem I don't want to bore you with a
lecture on ethics but you know the old
you know trolleys going down a path six
people gonna get killed one person on
the other side of the track if you flip
the switch one person dies not six do
you want to do that those kind of
calculations it turns out we do this all
the time we do this now for example when
we set the speed limit in the United
States to 55 miles an hour that means a
certain number of people will die every
year if instead you set the speed limit
to 45 miles an hour you will save lives
so why not do that well because we want
to get to work on time and we don't want
to drive 45 miles an hour on the freeway
and so we as a society have decided the
trade-off between a life and getting to
work and and if you think I'm joking
about this take a look at the Department
of Transportation on their website is a
memo on the statistical value of a life
and that number nine point one million
dollars that's the value that they used
to assign to your life my life in
calculating speed limits in order to
balance cost and benefit so we do this
right now and if we're going to develop
truly powerful AI the eye is gonna have
to do this on our behalf and the
question is how so that's the troubling
thing with the four laws of robotics
committed suicide because it couldn't
resolve that dilemma between the zero
than first law so not to like forget
what it was just not a great outcome but
you know that actually could be the
optimal outcome you know in the grand
scheme of things yes maybe back there
and then we'll go back down here between
once and needs financial decisions like
say if I wanted to liquidate my
portfolio to buy a boat that seems like
a pretty bad idea and so like an ethical
ie I might prevent me from doing that
but Mia is like a human being might
really enjoy like being out in the ocean
and so it seems like there's like a line
of where it's like a really bad ethical
decision that someone should prevent you
from making it right so this is exactly
where the issues are gonna arise and
where we have to think about how much
paternalism we want to instill in our a
I and how much we want to allow
individuals to override these
recommendations my guess is that
initially there's gonna be a lot of over
writing of these kinds of suggestions
but eventually if the AI gets good
enough and ends up knowing you better
than you know yourself if that ever
happens I know it seems kind of crazy
but let me give you one example of how
good AI is so I I enjoy playing chess on
chess calm I'm not very good at it but
I've done these exercises where not only
do I not get the right answers for the
exercise
I can't even understand what the answers
are when I'm told what they are because
the the chess program is going five six
seven steps ahead I can barely look two
steps ahead and so but I now have
confidence that the AI is better than I
am even though I can't understand it I
believe that the AI is better than I am
what if we get to a point where
financial AI knows a lot more about
what's gonna happen in the stock market
next year what's gonna happen with
macroeconomic conditions what's going to
happen with your own personal conditions
your health what if they factor all of
that in and like a chess engine they
just know so much more than you do that
you know buying that that surfboard or
whatever you want is gonna cause you
tremendous grief in three years time and
you don't even know it might we ever get
there exactly that's right so but but as
a as somebody who would parrot a
computer scientist I would say it's just
a matter of degree it's not a matter of
different characteristic you know
checkers is now a completely solved
problem we actually know what the
optimal strategy for chess is from
beginning to end that was solved about
ten years ago
checkers finite checkers not chess
checkers that's right and so there may
be a residual amount of uncertainty that
we will never be able to get to but
never is a long time and I don't know
how much technology is needed to be able
to deal with that situation or I
remember you don't need an AI that's
perfect you just need an AI that's
better than you and the question is how
long does it take for us to get an ad
it's better than you with chess we're
already there we look at Herbert Simon I
I wish Simon were alive today because he
would just be blown away that Garry
Kasparov cannot even understand some of
these chess moves when Garry Kasparov
says oh that's a computer move I don't
know what that is that's amazing to me
so might we get there with financial AI
I think we can but it may take another
twenty or thirty years but I think we
can get there with the
people in this room I think we can get
there yes down here question and then in
light of what you just said how should
financial regulation evolve for this
incoming and I'm quoting the one recent
issue of The Economist and unavoidable
final AI takeover of financial services
thank you
well for one thing I believe that
financial regulators need to learn more
computer science they need to hire more
computer scientists and they are I
believe it or not the SEC is actually
been hiring people that are data
scientists and understand how these AI
systems are working and I believe that
actually by using these techniques
regulators can do a better job of
regulating they can regulate much more
efficiently by using technology they're
not there yet but they're getting there
more importantly I think eventually
we're gonna have to think seriously
about how we digitize our legal
interactions and I know that Frank
Partnoy and choppy are teaching a course
on algorithm in the law so it's
happening now but most lawyers are not
computer scientists they're not even
trained in computing so I think that's
really where we need to make the biggest
change which is to start thinking about
the law and our interactions of the law
as something that can actually be
understood algorithmically it shouldn't
be hard and there's some really
interesting conundrums it there's one
story that I have to tell because Cioffi
and other computer scientists are here
so it turns out that in the 1940s at the
Institute for Advanced Study I think was
1940s curt girdle the famous logician
happened to be there and he was about to
take us test for citizenship and as part
of the citizenship test you're gonna get
asked questions about the Constitution
and so he had to read the Constitution
and and he spent a lot of time reading
it and so the day came for him to go to
the judge in those days you have to see
a judge and the judge would ask you
questions and so girdled didn't know how
to drive so he needed to be driven so he
got a ride from Believe It or Not Albert
Einstein
and I think it was von Neumann the two
of them this is the absolutely true
story you can read it in who got
Einsteins office it's a book that was
published decades ago so they gave him a
ride and along the way girdle said
something interesting he said you know I
read the Constitution and I realized
something it is possible in a completely
legal way to turn this country into a
dictatorship the Constitution allows it
and I have an algorithm that will do
that
and now this was right in the middle of
the Cold War and so you know Einstein
and Vine oi says no no no no no you do
not want to mention this at that when
the judge asks you what do you think
about Stalin and the dictatorship you do
not want to say oh that can happen here
too and so you know I wonder you know if
we had Shafie and Silvio McCauley and
some of the other Turing Award winners
read our Constitution or read corporate
governance documents what kind of things
would they find and what would be
possible what could computer scientists
tell us about legal interactions and
governance that we don't know I think
quite a lot what's that Terms of Service
other yeah well here oh and then back
here thank you for the motivating speech
I just want to ask this is not about
ethics it's more about emotional
reaction to different situations of like
human nature so what if we get to a day
where no matter by oai or by other means
or by like psychology or neuroscience we
can fully exploit this human nature and
we can fully understand the patterns of
human emotional reaction to everything
around us well there be such a day or
we'll human nature our pattern of
emotional reaction to the outer world
also evolved with our knowledge of this
world yeah there's no doubt that human
behavior will evolve to deal with these
technologies whether or not you can
predict how they evolve I think you can
and so I believe that there is
eventually our ability to be able to
make certain kinds of forecasts that
will allow us to compute equilibria
between the various different species
that are Co evolving I maybe there are
chaotic components of the system that
you'll never be able to forecast but
there is a significant enough element
and a significant enough regularity
human behavior that you can go pretty
far along the way there's an enormous
amount of potential right now and I
think it's just really a field that's
beginning to to get off the ground with
you know people in neuroscience
collaborating people in computer science
and engineering there's just so many
things that are able to be done that
that don't fit into any one single field
that's kind of the fun of an
organization like the Simons Institute
it's not just for computer scientists
there are all sorts of interesting
people here and many schools are
starting up various different computer
science colleges if you will so I think
that there's a lot more that that can be
done yeah or is it Shafi did you oh okay
okay
over here thank you for that talk so I
agree with you ai is going to be
probably the best investor out there
they're probably going to be multiple
eyes right because of the amount of data
because of Moore's Law because they're
able to process things much better than
us humans so the question for you is is
the end state AI trading with AI and
we're not gonna have any human investors
around at the end that we're just gonna
be at the end the customers of an AI
investors that are doing all the work
for us you know I think that that might
be possible although I think it's gonna
take us a very long time for the simple
reason that the complexity of the
investment process suggests that there
will always be a group of individuals
that are going to be able to provide
unique services to individual investors
that are seeking those services so I
don't mean things like index funds index
funds are already now pretty much run by
AI I mean you know the portfolio
optimizers that can construct an SP
index fund they can do that you know at
the blink of an eye you don't need to
worry about a lot of oversight on the
management of those portfolios
but I'm thinking about you know hedge
fund strategies where somebody says I
want to look for unique opportunities in
the energy field you know when we have a
discovery of a particular kind of energy
technology I want to invest in that I
think that those are still going to
require human oversight but more and
more now I think it's going to be a
partnership between technology and human
judgment that we'll be able to make
those kinds of decisions
and in the end I really think that's
what technology does it's not
necessarily going to be replacing humans
altogether but it's going to change the
domain over which we spend our time and
you know add value to an investment
process thank you thank you
[Applause]